I would say story about the next-door
neighbor she was always kind of a loopy
broad and these giant giant firemen
there's got a big mustache and he they
knocked in the door and she goes hello
he goes how you doing I was right there
and she goes I'm okay and he goes were
you sitting outside on your on your air
conditioner and she was of 16 for some
she goes she goes um I was yeah and he
goes do you think that's normal and she
goes uh yeah I was just do you think
that's you think that New York firemen
because you think that that was normal
to be sitting on top of your your
organism 16 floors up she goes yeah I
don't know what this isn't he goes
through her she goes oh she just
collapses and he grabbed her and there
she was obviously yeah and they saved
her life I mean you know god bless those
guys but it was such a it was Robin and
she she moved out of that apartment yeah
but my parents scooped it up tight moved
by the parents yeah I just never feel so
bad associations in a crisis yeah but
these giant men these giant men in all
their gear like they're built like you
just when you're a little woman or even
a man I mean they're just at your door
like that you you have no chance
just take me she's they just scooped her
up
there's a giant heroes these giant
savers you get fat Jen I am fat no
you're not that I'm chubby for sure no
yeah well I don't I gotta get so much
cooler I don't see it a chop on you look
a big chin big chance hey Jen Jen what's
up bro you start wearing a hat and iPad
for no reason I had a dream about you I
had a dream now that I remember god damn
it I dream that my wife was watching you
sing and my wife went does he know he's
got hair like that I went what she goes
he is just fantastic with that hair and
I was like yourself gots to you hey
[ __ ] you're you're lusting chamber like
we never post this but like when it like
say you're in Tampa [ __ ] laughter this
when you're in Tampa right
sold out around Houston or Wilbur
theater Willie's post but I'm Friday
night I sent the Icehouse 10 o'clock
show set the ice house and it's 105
degrees out no one's coming out of their
house I show up and I Drive away out
there and there's seven people around no
there's seven people and the comics too
hot the comics are eating all the dicks
in the room like everyone's bombing of
course and I wonder as don't you I want
to put it on my feet and be like
everyone all comics and people talk
about how glorious the Comic Life is how
good this is sometimes how it goes down
this is what's we haven't seven people
and seven people you still got perform
like this is and I drove all the way
down while your energy body right dude
all the energy so I want to put that but
I thought I saw we get mad at me so I
didn't do it I didn't want them back
what the [ __ ] so I didn't post it but
they might say it can be exhausting well
I was so worried about Tampa i walked in
i the the lady run that i love Franco
what happened it's one called a bomb
scare something she's like no sweetie
it's the weather well it's for me I was
worried about Tampa because I told you I
said at one point in the beginning of
week like nice old
69 tickets than 112 and it's a 350 room
seat so that was icing I called Martin
Marty who's awesome but there's Michael
dude we got to ramp up something I'm
worried about this and I thought it was
gonna be I was gonna dick so that all
four shows because they come they come I
don't know what kind of last-minute
whatever it is but I we energy in my
body as I was flying out there thinking
that I was on a plane to I was like I
don't want to do is I want to quit
comedy I'm really depressed such a for
and then when they get they said now
we're sold out we're gonna sell out I
called you I text you you go [ __ ] I
go no I think it's true and then I was
like whoa okay then you got seven people
in a room how many times I play that
well but throughout the year it's not my
[ __ ] it's not my show that's not my
thing and when you doing such and trying
to work on stuff and you go in town to
TAS a long drive yeah well I don't mind
the drive I thought it's funny like him
post that it be like you've read the
bike of Brad Pitt went into comedy I'd
be like dude come on man and then just
crunch add enough he's up there
maybe Brad Pitt was onstage crushing
yeah yeah
I wouldn't want to kill him but then
really friendly to his job is to
dry-hump like Jennifer Aniston and Jay
Angelina Jolie in movies he gets to
dry-hump them for twenty million dollars
and then he gets to come home to a
beautiful last wife and kids and then
also he's funny yeah that one kid oh
yeah he's all about it might be too much
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] my teeth like
an old woman like a vampire vampire like
a hot dog in the bottom of the bag if
that's a vis align I can't imagine what
they used to
Dule what I'm with wheeze out one of
them back open garage I took a peek at
their part in this dude was passed out I
had these short cutoff shorts jean
shorts is like balls were barely hanging
out the front and the big gut and he's
just has his American hat flag on our
side cough I was if I appreciate someone
with good wet the way they dress and the
airport's all go Airport swaggy of the
day issues of the day and I liked him I
was like here port swag of the day not
met the jean shorts and then after I
post I thought [ __ ] man would be seized
well you're very famous now it does
change it I know I'm not making fun of
this you are sheep no I like his G yes
[ __ ] own your [ __ ] own it
you were you were looking down on him
you saw that big gut and he were how
dare you were short deny where you had
the same history way shorter bro but
this one way shorter warm I was jealous
because I was hot know this but I'm
trying to be a politician right now
you're doing saying you're doing Sammy
Sosa right now you Sammy Sosa just only
ever if you can kill him with humor you
can get out of fight I was I'm mister
like hey let's talk about this you know
but I take as a story one time I was I
was pulling into a 7-eleven and this
sort of skinhead biker bald head guy
with the mustache and tattoos all over
you know I almost hit him and he looked
at me like you know he was like you
mother you know I was like hey sorry bro
sorry I parked but when I walked in he
was standing there in line and he locked
eyes with me like word he locked eyes
with me like oh I'll kill your black ass
that type of thing and I locked eyes
back in my mind I was like don't break I
cut and like I was like oh my god what
if I don't break eye contact what's
gonna happen and then he looked away
from me and I as I passed on my land who
thank God you broke sorry I just got
sorry I already said sorry I already had
like a you know God
another time I almost hit a guy I was
backing up I hate pedestrians because
they think they own this is a three ton
vehicle bro but I thinks about half this
is gonna kill you guys I don't care what
the goddamn government says about you
have the right away you should be
looking at what's going on so the guy
wasn't moving you know he's a mover big
burly blue-collar mover guy I almost hit
him explains my card he's like I can't
when he's going on and on and I said hey
relax I'm sorry there you go it's okay
but you know what though I saw him
though I saw him like go from like he
was ready yeah and I was like it's cold
man he's always you know I did he did he
would have been like what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah yes exactly within the situation
like why don't you [ __ ] watch it you
go ahead engage I just was like you know
what chill bro I I have that lie down
I'll go down Pacific I've already
relaxed when you do that me to your word
that's five by the way by the way you're
a fighter
not a I'm not you but you can have it
yourself you can't use some just a smart
guy to use man club works at SEMA glove
works he's only one kicking the [ __ ] a
glove works and it's a boxing bag he's
like pastry chef the army but we're
working on meat today he's over there
frosting like a Billy Jack but anyways I
feel like when guys the guys that really
can handle themselves they're not making
I'm a bunch of no no no and I make it a
major right